still have
a lot of belief in baker as a
quarterback his talent
and what we think he can become in the
nfl looking forward to seeing what kevin
and alex and his staff
do with baker this spring and into the
fall we're really excited about his
future and i'm really excited about the
work that kevin's going to do with him
andrew barry the new gm of the cleveland
browns who was in the room when baker
mayfield was the first overall pick in
2018 he would later leave for a year
with the eagles before returning as the
gm expressing belief in baker mayfield
look i want to see who the
real baker mayfield is he was great in
2018 last year not great 22 touchdown
passes 21 interceptions his 78.8 passer
rating was 31st among starters ahead of
only andy dalton who had 78.3 it was a
bad bad year statistically for baker
mayfield although i had a couple of
receivers who were over a thousand yards
i don't know whether it was freddie
kitchen's being the head coach and not
being involved like he was in 2018 with
baker mayfield but whatever the case
they need more out of baker they need
more 2018 baker unless 2019 baker
uh great promo mike for today's part of
my take we have baker mayfield as our
guest and we get into all of that and
i'm telling you
a minor set back for a major comeback
baker mayfield's going to be fine all
you haters out there i've made a list i
got everyone's name mike are you on that
list
no
are you sure no
no look i'm i'm on the fence right now
oh oh i'm on the fence i'm on the fence
he's got to prove it 29 i will write a
bad year i will write you down on the
list right now go ahead i might write
you down okay mike florio
he's got to get past that doesn't he
have to get past that
no he's got a mature passion
against anyone and everyone that ever
says anything bad about him because
they're going to say bad things about it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports